hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play the things in the night I
don't know that's cooking it oh man the
the the manikin that made me a jerk so
jerk my knee so hard that I accidentally
hit the desk so I knocked my okay
so there's a monster just standing out
there but I'm not gonna go that way cuz
that's just silliness
what's this ha I can't go in the lab
door that's right murder murder do okay
so I need to sneaky sneak without
looking at him I'm assuming I don't know
which one it was clay to him but all I
know is I'm staying away from that room
he's just staring at me
okay so maybe the brother was up to good
I'm open this have that Hey
ah you made me run out of oil looking at
some stupid thing okay so it's a dead
guy fantastic
what do I care it's that clay oh who
cares okay okay okay today I finally got
a new add-on in my room I had to help
master with his experiments so I let him
give me some kind of an injection at
least that's what he called it he told
me that I'm not allowed to talk any Bell
about this with anyone even got me some
more coin this month
I got another injection today and had to
drink some red stuff it was really nasty
I'm feeling really bad and can't stop
itching feels like I'm gonna throw up so
I informed the master about my condition
and all he said was good very good
what is he done to me my hair is falling
out and my skin is getting really smelly
and hard to touch Master said he was
gonna take me into the lab hope I
conceived in my new add-on at least one
more time
so what's this add-on some behind the
bookshelf something
what is this add-on okay so why did I
come in here to discover that add-on
that is I just know they're gonna throw
me a man and consider me
I really freakin hate me I hate him I
had more than anything in this game okay
I don't see anything for an add-on I
don't see a painting that I can move
besides this one okay I don't see
anything he's still there I think I see
him down there
okay what was the point I'm gonna go
back try to talk to this lady person no
that was you hi Sarah Sarah baby talk to
me Sarah Sarah come on Sarah
I broke the needle cuz I break
everything I touch apparently he's still
down there was like nothing here was the
air whoa one there I don't know alright
I don't see anything the note didn't
give me much information told me that
the guy was turning into something
I don't know yah-hoo I gotta be
something to do with this gigantic
bookshelf I mean really why else would
it be here if it wasn't to be moved but
there's no book that can be pulled
there's nothing like that it's all very
straightforward ridiculousness
ridiculous I see so they like some
switch oh man oh wait a minute what's
that huh what's this what's all this
then huh
what's going on here there's gotta be
like some switch in the room that pulls
the bookshelf or something I don't know
but I can't see it okay let's just go
meet my brother hey brother how you
doing
there's a room with that
oh here he comes that's a room with
mannequins so what do I do about okay
that's what I do about it
hey what you got
[Music]
my brother's coming to say hi
maybe it's a special scripted sequence
for the brother to come in here and bash
my brains in well you went away that's
weird but anyway I'm kind of at a loss
now because I I didn't get a key from
any gear or anything like that I didn't
get anything so moderately confussed
hmm it's gotta be staring me right in
the face oh he's still there and he's
coming back
screw you
Loretta you're not good to me
okay I think he's just patrolling the
hallway I got to go to the cellar now
I'm just gonna run for it if I can I
think he's down the other hallway so
we're going going right now right now
we're going I've been putting it off
actually but oh you gotta be kidding me
I think I did anyway
oh did he finally go away was in here
how did I miss this
I've been working here for 10 years now
and Evan never had someone put out the
fire the torches what the hell could
they be doing with them now it's so dark
in the servants Hall wait I can't see at
night so to avoid that I put them back
up but then again when I wake up they
are gone someone's going to pay for this
and I bet it's masters son doing it Suns
doing it to make my life even harder but
there was only one Sun in the house I
tried to stay up last night to see how
the torches are getting took getting
took off the wall I waited until it was
dark then I heard a noise so I looked
down the hall and something was moving
in the kitchen I tried to sneak up them
but they were well I don't know but they
looked dead and made a terrifying noise
so I ran back to my bedroom as fast as I
couldn't lock the door tomorrow I'll
tell my master what happened okay but
I've been in here and I just missed that
note
cuz I'm an idiot oh and I'm out of oil
now I'm completely out of oil darn it
and that's locked but there's like a I
thought I saw some sort of red glow
behind there creepy I don't have
anything Sarah and her stupid bobby pin
didn't do me any good huh maybe there's
something in this room I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know okay I don't see a thing I
don't see a thing I must be missing
something very fundamental here but I'm
just not seeing it I've tried every door
open and there's supposed to be
something that can help me in this guy's
room but there is not her I can't even
have my lantern anymore because I am out
of oil so my life is travesty I'm gonna
join you in the bed here because there
was something here that's clickable but
I don't know what something-something
okay all right all right
these are staring me right in the face
because if it is I'm gonna be very upset
very upset unlikely to be staring me in
the face now considering that I can't
see anything
however Sarah Sarah
answer the door Sarah
what's that I hear rain or water no let
me go back to the kitchen
ah man it's aggravating you know you get
stuck when you think you're just about
to make progress and you end up getting
stuck
I don't know hopefully that's been
straight the whole time I did a it up
like my face in the corner of the shot
it's stuck and then it's like nothing
you can do there's no clues I hate
getting stuck more than anything I think
it is stuck but anyway it happens and I
got a deal with it
I need a crowbar or something which I
did not find anywhere painting on the
wall lovely decor by the way maybe there
was something else down here and I get
but I cannot see ah hello ah look at
this oh good desk
oh yeah oh yeah mmm
oil love it what are we gonna be very
conservative about it let me take the
other side just in case there was
something there and the body's gone
look at that look green George's there's
nothing down here either nothing at all
yeah hey hey so why did I have to go
what I'm curious about is why I had to
go to another dimension to get to a
place to go into another portal that
brought me back to the same dimension
where the castle is because the castle
is right outside of the village how stop
it
you know it's literally right there so I
don't know what the deal is all right
there's got to be something here how do
I get behind you I know I know I know it
does I know there's a secret behind you
I just have to find I see it I can see
the door to find out who you I just have
to find out I just have to find me find
find you
I got to discover your secret I could
see that garden
I'm not gonna waste the oil it's gonna
fire
how do I get to your edition take all
your books off the shelf
that's the secret as the day grit cuz if
all the books are off it'll be less
heaviness and then I gotta move it with
my bare hands
this tote set o log such genius smart
person why is this covered in webbing up
to that point get out of the way maybe
there's something under the desk behind
the desk
grandfather clock under the painting in
the dresser nope there is nothing
absolutely nothing
I've checked every square inch there is
nothing nothing
had servants bedroom I don't good in
their riches room who cares riches in a
hole closed room who cares I'm actually
all that time so maybe if you guys can
give you a little hint err on what to do
so maybe if any of you guys played this
one maybe drop me a little hint in the
comment section so thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
bye bye